as a human upper Moon 4 huntengu was a
compulsive liar in his own mind he was
always a victim and anyone who got in
his way was a bully he had a victim
complex and he twisted fact to make
himself look innocent in reality huntegu
was a ruthless criminal who did terrible
things he stole from people and he also
murdered people across Japan eventually
he was caught but before he could be
brought to Justice muzon turned him into
a demon huntengu is a major villain in
Demon Slayer season 3. unfortunately
many countries like the US cannot watch
it on Netflix that's why I use
expressvpn to change my online location
to India and watch the new episodes as
soon as they come out try it for free
using the link in the comments and as
you watch Demon Slayer season 3 on
Netflix with expressvpn don't be fooled
by haunted Goose tricks you can't trust
a word he says